ouais c'est un cadeau accompagné d'un
poème ce sont des boules de bain
colorées pour qu'on puisse prendre un
bain tous les deux tu te fous de ma
gueule
qui va avec riche
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça sans déconner
écoute dedans
mais qu'est-ce que je vais [ __ ] avec
des boules de bain écouter le poème il
est touchant
je pense à toi Baba je vois du rose du
bleu et même du magenta arc-en-ciel de
mon cœur je t'offre aujourd'hui ces
boules pleines de couleurs je te propose
de partager cette boule de bain toi moi
une baignoire et tu auras mon boule
entre les mains
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le poème m'a appelé
le poème est pas mal le poème est pas
mal autant le cadeau il est passé
tu rappelle qu'on prend les cadeaux du
plus riche au moins riche Bernard
Montiel
[Rires]
partout tu dépenses rien c'est vrai
alors moi je vous ai trouvé quelque
chose vraiment d'unique et de rare ça va
toi oui ça va très bien non je regarde
parce que c'est j'ai mis beaucoup
d'émotion à le faire oui c'est un truc
extrêmement rare c'est une pièce unique
en plus attends
[Applaudissements]
et c'est quelque chose de rare vous
voyez c'est une chose rare dédicacée par
moi-même
[Rires]
je te souhaite une longue carrière comme
la mienne Bernard Montiel
ancienne photo en plus
il y a des gens regardez et pour Cyril
un jour peut-être tu seras au top
longtemps comme moi courage Bernard
[Applaudissements]
je vous souhaite le meilleur en fait on
va du plus riche au moins riche médaille
on se connaît bien et je sais à quel
point vous êtes un amoureux de l'art
toutes les formes d'art
littéraire un couple tantôt mélomane
j'ai donc longuement réfléchi c'est
pourquoi je t'offre enfin je nous offre
une soirée tous les deux et pas
n'importe où
à l'opératoire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et et
je propose qu'on aille voir les capulés
les particuliers comme ça Opéra Bastille
vas-y avance et je te rejoindrai
pour découvrir mes cadeaux du plus riche
au moins riche
si vous êtes avec nous bien sûr mardi
vous retrouverez le cadeau de Benjamin
Castaldi
toi c'est toi maintenant avec tout ce
que tu as mis de côté c'est des poissons
[Rires]
et puis j'ai prévu j'ai le cœur j'ai
voulu quelque chose un espèce de retour
aux sources quelque chose de très
personnel à laquelle je suis très très
attaché quelque chose est vraiment
qu'elle je suis très attaché une photo
de ma chatte
[Applaudissements]
ça fait longtemps que je voulais la voir
tu vas être magnifique chatte marine
[Musique]
on continue les cadeaux
avec on va d'utilisation du plus riche
aux moins riche et je vais d'ailleurs
maintenant passer par Gilles Verdez
alors c'est un cadeau qu'on vous a fait
avec Fatou ou alors d'ailleurs merci
pour le Tibo comment il fait tous ce
matin et c'est une tenue traditionnelle
sénégalaise je vous laisse ouvrir
nous aimerions que vous portiez le jour
de notre mariage
reste la même et si vous voulez bien
l'essayer
[Applaudissements]
je vais être magnifique avec ça je vous
jure c'est pas mal tu sais que la
semaine prochaine je fais des missions
comme ça
et vous savez et Sénégal la Dakar
l'émission et regarder tous les jours et
là-bas vous avez une extraordinaire
je te remercieras ma Fatou d'amour que
j'ai pas pu appeler hier soir parce que
j'étais un petit peu en retard mais tu
dis que je l'embrasse fort et elle m'a
écrit ce matin avec toi et franchement
Fatou elle est là elle est dans mon cœur
et à jamais dans mon cœur je rappelle
qu'on va du plus riche au Maurice alors
j'oublie parce que vous n'avez pas de
cadeau devant vous les deux la frite
elle est chez elle
les jumelles de l'apéritif
[Applaudissements]
si vous aviez là de partir là-dedans
c'est quoi alors est-ce qu'on le fait
maintenant vous l'offre maintenant c'est
quoi c'est en fait on a envie pour votre
cadeau de donner de notre personne
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
qu'est-ce que vous voulez faudrait juste
un peu vous reculer comme ça alors tu
peux pas bouger
je suis à deux doigts d'acheter la
police
[Applaudissements]
mettez-vous tranquillement
[Rires]
va continuer avec toi je suis assez déjà
c'est vrai que je t'ai mis loin
c'est une question de patrimoine des
autres ils ont 150 ans
quand tu passes le de l'autre côté de la
barrière à un moment
alors tu m'as arnaqué je sais que tu
adores le paddle t'adore le tennis et
les moyens de non je suis pas les moyens
de mettre beaucoup d'argent j'ai chopé
quelque chose qui est très très
difficile à voir c'est quoi c'est un
cadeau ça fait un mois et demi que je
suis sûr que je connais très bien
plusieurs grands joueurs de tennis et
ben je te laisse ouvrir mais c'est
il y a beaucoup d'émotions ça a l'air
fort
écoute bien c'est collector c'est le
slip que portait Nadal pendant le
dernier c'est celui-là
il est
blanc
il est incroyable c'est exactement ça
bah merci merci vraiment c'est un très
beau cadeau je le mets avec la chatte à
Daniel
[Applaudissements]
on est toujours torturé on sait pas quoi
offrir alors moi j'ai tenu à vous en
faire une veste que j'ai chiné tous
l'été non
pourquoi mais c'est à moi ça connard
[Applaudissements]
qui a fait son petit effet que je
mettrai dans mon salon d'ailleurs
les gens viendronter
enfin sera la première fois
alors alors
apparemment quel bruit fait
elle a une chatte bruyante
alors oui vous savez que c'est un peu
compliqué pour moi financièrement
néanmoins je voulais marquer le coup non
et vous offrir quelque chose de d'unique
c'est le dernier exemplaire après après
il y en aura plus donc je vous demande
de le garder précieusement avec vous il
s'agit de mon RIB
[Applaudissements]
j'y ai joint un euro pour le virement
instantané puisque c'est payant
je le mets également avec la chatte
plus qu'un j'étais pas du tout compte
tous les cadeaux je voulais dire
franchement bravo vous avez quand même
travaillé non franchement bravo c'était
toujours bien pensé même si c'est de la
merde
[Rires]
et donc il y a le dernier cadeau de
Béatrice et Delphine
c'est quoi c'est un cadeau donc
apparemment c'est un cadeau commun
mobile
c'est un cadeau en 3D d'accord
ah ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dire que le prochain anniversaire c'est
Gilles Verdez il doit se dire je vais
kiffer bravo Béatrice bravo
[Applaudissements]